hello everyone and welcome back to
Jordan has no life my name is Jordan and
as you probably could have guessed I
have no life because I am making this
video on July 4th instead of hanging out
with my friends so I gotta go do that
after I bust this one out anyways
thinking of renaming the channel to
clickbaiters Incorporated simply because
the majority of this video is going to
be spent covering Cassandra not mongodb
which takes about 30 seconds to explain
so let's go ahead and knock that out and
get started alright so as promised I
mentioned that we were going to talk
about mongodb first so let's go ahead
and do that so mongodb is one of those
databases that I think in you know kind
of actual like pragmatic scenario is
pretty easy to use it's well documented
it's got a lot of nice features that
make it good as developer but at least
from like a systems design interview
perspective
it's nothing that crazy and so that's
why we can go through it pretty quickly
typically uses a b tree index it
uses acid transactions if you want them
and typically you would use it with
single leader replication and that would
just be sharded in order to get better
right throughput and so all of this
stuff is pretty pretty similar to your
typical SQL database
now obviously I shouldn't say Obviously
but in reality a lot of these features
are configurable so you can kind of plug
and play them as you want but the point
is I think this is probably generally
how people are using mongodb
even still the biggest difference
between mongodb and a SQL database which
is why mongodb gets the title of a nosql
database is that mongodb is document
oriented so what is a document well it's
effectively just a nice deeply nested
Json structure of data that you can
store in your database and what that
allows you to do is have a little bit
more flexibility in terms of what you're
actually storing so for example if we
wanted to store like a person object
here would be the ID of it and then we
could have a nice little Json document
of a name and a link God knows of what
but that guy Jordan has a long life so
again that offers us some flexibility
beyond the traditional rigid SQL
relational table model where everything
has to have the same exact columns
so that's pretty much mongodb we'll talk
about how it compares to Cassandra but
in order to do so we have to actually
talk about Cassandra itself so Cassandra
uses something known as the wide column
data model so instead of being a nested
structure really the only requirements
in Cassandra for your data is that you
have these two Fields right here and
frankly really only a cluster key the
sword key is optional but basically
we've got a cluster key we've got a sort
key and then pretty much everything else
in every single row is optional and you
can either have them there or you don't
have to it's really not too big of a
deal so let's go ahead and keep talking
about this
first we're going to start by talking
about partitioning Cassandra so if you
recall we've got a cluster key and a
sort key and that is going to do things
for us in partitioning what it basically
means is that we are going to decide how
we're partitioning each row based on the
value of its clustering key and so that
configuration for partitioning is
actually going to be shared via gossip
protocol so every single node can go
ahead and just like gossip
if you recall from our consistent
hashing video this would be like our
hash ring and this is going to say which
keys are going on which node so in this
case all the keys in this range are
let's say on this node over here and so
just in general our hash ring is going
to tell us which notes go or rather
which rows go where and each node is
going to share that with one another via
a gossip protocol if a node were to go
down
these guys would both start gossiping
not to one another and eventually
everyone would agree on the partitioning
state of the whole system and then of
course I did even forget to write this
but we've got a local index
with a sort key
So within each partition the rows are
sorted based on the value of this guy
here a sword key and keep in mind the
reason I call that a local index is
because they are only sorted within that
single partition if we're looking at a
different partition then the sort key is
pretty much irrelevant across them so in
Cassandra it's actually a very very
opinionated system about how they want
reads and rights to go and typically it
is very strongly recommended that all
reads and writes go to Just One
partition there is very little support
for distributed transactions if you're
running Cassandra you don't want to be
running two-phase commit ideally all of
your reads are coming from one partition
at a time and all of your rights are
going to one partition at a time so it's
very important to keep in mind now let's
go ahead and talk about replication
because replication is probably what
makes Cassandra the most unique out of
all the systems that we've discussed so
far so first off we're actually using
leaderless replication so this is the
first time we're discussing a database
that is kind of generally used in this
type of fashion and if you recall what
that means is that you can do things
like have quorums so you would write to
and read from a majority of nodes and
although this doesn't technically
achieve strong consistency it does mean
that generally speaking when you write
and then you read using a quorum node
right after that you should be able to
see that written value in at least one
of the nodes of course that is
configurable though if you don't want to
have to use quorums you can say rights
can only go to a single node reads can
only come from a single node and that's
really all just depending on how
comfortable you are with eventual
consistency and Stillness of data in
order to make sure that there is less
stale data on each node Cassandra will
do things like read repair and
anti-entropy so read repair if you
recall is basically saying like oh shoot
you know this guy doesn't have the value
from our original right over here so
once this client sees the value he's
going to write back to this database and
read repair it anti-entropy on the other
hand would be the occasional sending of
data via a Merkle tree
from one database to the next in order
to make sure that they have consistent
States using a Merkle tree allows
sending lesser data over the network
because you only compare the differences
in data between the two tables
then in addition of course whenever we
use leaderless replication anything
other than single replication opens us
up to right conflicts and when we have
right conflicts how do we resolve them
in particular Cassandra chooses to use
last right wins or lww so obviously
there are some problems with this namely
that we can't trust timestamps in
distributed systems there's clock drift
there's Network lag all of this other
stuff and so as a result we can have
lost rights if I write at the same time
as you and my right happens to just
barely have an earlier timestamp mine is
effectively just gone from the system
and I'm going to have no clue what
happened so keep in mind that when
you're using Cassandra technically you
don't have great data Integrity
additionally
another alternative to Cassandra which
is basically the same exact thing is
called ryak this is another type of
database system however the one main
difference between riac and Cassandra is
that as opposed to using last right wins
ryak gives us the option to use crdts or
conflict-free replicated data types in
order to help us resolve our right
conflicts and I have a video dedicated
to those that I made I don't know a
month or two ago
okay so now let's look at just a single
database node in Cassandra because we've
talked about the partitioning the
replication but at least within a single
node Cassandra does some nice stuff in
order to help performance which is that
it uses an LSM tree and SS tables in
contrast to a b tree so what does this
actually help us do well it's a little
bit better for rights because this guy
right here aka the LSM tree
is in memory
and that means that all rights are first
going to memory before they have to go
to disk when they're eventually flushed
to an SS table this is in contrast to a
b tree where your right originally goes
to disk and as a result writes are a bit
slower but reads are a little bit faster
on B trees so keep that difference in
mind as well another thing is that
Cassandra does not really fully support
acid transactions it really only likes
row level locking so they you know
within a row your value is definitely
going to be correct but if you wanted to
do something like a read modify update
transaction on multiple rows you might
have trouble doing something like that
or at least Cassandra wasn't originally
made with that intention ideally most of
the rights that you should be doing
should just be going to one row at a
time and that is the best way to really
use Cassandra
so let's do a quick conclusion so that I
can go meet up with some friends and
stop being such a nerd basically mongodb
is really really good for when you need
the data Integrity of a relational
database type of system if you want acid
transactions if you want to be able to
run two-phase commit in order to perform
distributed transactions then mongodb
does support all of that obviously the
the speed is going to be more comparable
to something like a SQL database however
it's really really nice to be able to
have the data flexibility that you do by
using this document oriented data model
on the other hand Cassandra is extremely
different than that it's got like a very
opinionated type of way of using it
where basically you want to always be
reading from and writing to one
partition at a time
in terms of reads those reads can read
multiple rows at a time but ideally for
writes you're probably writing one row
at a time as well
but at the same time as a result of this
you don't have great data guarantees due
to things like write conflicts you can
just have rights getting clobbered or
removed and due to the lack of acid
transactions and distributed
transactions if you plan on doing things
like that you should be very very
careful and you might even have bugs in
your code if you're trying to code them
up on your own so a good case for
Cassandra in general because I think
it's good to kind of outline one of
these would be something like a chat
application like Facebook Messenger the
reason being that you're Often
bottlenecked by rights there because
everyone's going to be writing so many
messages all of the reads that you do
are probably going to be for one chat at
a time and they're always going to be
ordered by timestamp and so something
like using chat ID as the cluster key
for partitioning so that all of your
messages are on the same partition could
be really really useful and then of
course to make that index read faster we
can basically just sort by timestamp
and again this is going to be the
generalized case which we would be
reading those messages it's going to be
very rare that we would ever have to
write to two partitions at once because
it's never like you're sending a chat to
or you're never sending a message to
multiple chats at once but at the same
time you're probably always just going
to be writing one message at a time and
it's always going to be going to one
chat at a time so this is a really
really good use case anyways guys I hope
this video was useful as you can see
there are some pretty distinctive use
cases between Cassandra and mongodb and
it's very important to understand this
difference because in an actual
interview when someone says do you want
to use a SQL table or a nosql table and
then you say nosql and they say which
one you better know which one so have a
good one guys and I will see you in the
next one